انه يوم اخر من المفاوضات بين الجمهورين
والديمقراطيين والبيت الابيض مع بعض الامل
بالتوصل الى اتفاق يوم الخميس اطلب
الموافقه بالاجماع على انه بعد رفع الجلسه
ان يعود مجلس النواب الى الاجتماع غدا
كان هذا افضل مؤشر على ان الاتفاق ممكن
حيث كان من المنتظر ان يغادر اعضاء
الكونغرس يوم الخميس في اجازه تذكار
الموتى على ان يعودوا له طلب منهم ذلك
وزاد من معدلات التفاؤل قول رئيس مجلس
النواب كيفن مكارسي انه تم تحقيق تقدم في
مفاوضات يوم الاربعاء في البيت الابيض
عملنا لما بعد منتصف الليل وكان يوما جيدا
وحققنا بعض التقدم وما زالت هناك بعض
المشاكل العالقه وطلبت من الطاقم متابعه
العمل على مدار الساعه
ليس من الواضح بعد ما هي تفاصيل الاتفاق
المحتمل وما هي المصروفات التي سيوافق
الديمقراطيون على اقتطاعها مقابل رفع سقف
الدين وهم حتى صباح الخميس ما زالوا
غاضبين ويتحدثون عن دعم المحاربين القدامى
وبرامج المساعدات
المحاربون القدامى يواجهون مشكله بسبب
الجمهوريين الذين اخترعوا مشكله سقف الدين
ومع هذه التناقضات بدات الاسواق تشعر اكثر
بالضغوطات وبدات تتسرب معلومات من وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه عن انها ستدفع لاصحاب
السندات اولا لو لم يتوصل الطرفان الى
اتفاق
هناك خطط لدى جمعيات السندات والاسواق
لمتابعه العمل وتبادل السندات والتصرف
وكانه ليس هناك مشكله بدا الاطراف بتحقيق
تقدم ولكن وزاره الخزانه والاسواق تستعد
للسيناريو الاسوا والسيناريو الاسوا هو
عدم دفع الدوله للاجور والمعاشات عند ذلك
لا احد يعرف كيف تسير الاسواق في الغنم
العربيه واشنطن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات